this man has changed you know like
thousands of people's lives so every
[Music]
Valley so you can say for a week that's
it it looks like a stay high in a season
trash the property accepts if I pay cash
for it right now how much here except
for it we need to go to the London
mathematics says you're a piece of my
name is Glen Kirkham I'm 34 I live in
Blackpool I'm a father of three this is
a great look for you thanks
[Music]
so obviously I did in this documentary
to do a social experiment where I will
move to one of the poorest towns in the
UK go and live in someone's house who
has nothing no money at all and see if I
can teach them my knowledge and my
skills and see if I can make a poor
person become rich in one week I am
gonna have to sell today and the house
is a terrible horrible telling time what
happen that fear is palpable how many
people will be willing to walk into an
estate agent at nine o'clock on a Monday
morning ago what have you got some
grounding so how you like
plain ago breaking the fools I don't
need you I got my